reject nation greg and john here little
heads up
i'm going out of town this sunday for a
full
week with that in mind this guy's
working currently off of about
four hours of sleep all week
let's try to get everything done this
week and to get all the videos covered
for patreon next week got a lot of
filming and editing to get
done until midnight tonight we're back
in the winter soldier drops
non-stop party train and also many hours
ago i got
i don't know if it's a key word but i
got this you got
the thing i got the shot you've been
naded
and with that in mind got to get as much
filament up before
anything goes wrong with my body
and then of course in the middle of like
oh gotta move gotta move this film
theory video came out and i'm like well
everything can wait film theory's got a
video film theories videos
are incredible and i love their theory
videos so we're gonna watch the three
big twists
of falcon in the winter soldier let's
get down to bus nuts
look i know that disney is hyper aware
these days of what the internet's gonna
freak out about baby yoda and
mandalorian
boom immediately broke the internet slow
pan up on captain america holding thor's
hammer and end game
nothing better evan peters as quick
silver and wand division
big boner energy
that's his real name don't hit us with
that one youtube that's not on us that's
a disney thing they know the theories
they know the hashtags but most of all
they know how to manipulate the memes
but for their new series falcon and the
winter soldier i've got something they'd
never think of
something that would be on a complete
other tier of iconic
ladies and gentlemen to you i present
the meme
talk about fun make them call it falcon
punch have them say
once disney why did we never go there
with that i know at least not on video
i've i've had the thought at least once
what the hell falcone barge damn it
that's a missed opportunity then we
failed to be a very different
conversation right now we'd be like oh
that's what we said matt
you're stealing our jokes content thief
that we stole from smash
and now we're here glad we could pause
the video for that let's keep it going
wow hello internet that is longer than
the marvel crypt
characters red white and clickbait green
so let's say for a minute that you're
marvel
congratulations on your boatloads of
money but you also have yourself a
problem and avengers 3 had your big bad
throw a literal
moon at people and it wasn't even his
finishing move in the last major round
you mix together a decade's worth of
every character that has the potential
to sell an action figure
that's not a flattering steve so how do
you
top all of that well if the two disney
plus installments that kicked off this
new phase are any indication the
strategy wasn't to go wider
it was to go deeper sure one division on
the surface was a kooky offbeat riff on
sitcom tropes but underneath it was an
emotionally devastating exploration of
being trapped in your own personal
prison of grief trauma and loss
and now they're not the same good show
the falcon and the winter soldier
seems to be doing the exact same thing
what on the surface appeared to be a
rollicking buddy cop action movie with
two relatively overlooked faces from the
big team-ups is in actuality a series
tackling
the issues that come along with a
superhero wearing a national issues man
you know like the fact that not everyone
on the planet sees that flag and
immediately thinks oh hey
there's the good guy aren't the stars
and stripes a little old-fashioned
ah nothing quite like a disney plus
series that covers all those
family-friendly topics like
and the treatment geopolitics military
veterans racism and what it actually
means for a superhero to also be a
symbol of a country oh boy i'm gonna
have to block so
many uncles on facebook now that new
episodes of this are coming out you see
like i was concerned in a weird way
because
not really concerned concern is not the
correct don't use that word concerned
frightened ignore it ignore that word i
was feeling
like when we were seeing the trailers
was this show going to get like
political
feel like it would get political and
they emphasized so much action and stuff
and then when we did uh
our interview with um cary skoglen
director of falcon and wonder soldier
when we did that interview she was
talking about how this is going to
explore themes of
nationalism what it means to be a black
man in in america
would they have to take up the captain
america mantle
all that i was like oh boy this is gonna
be this is gonna be the keep your
politics out of my entertainment
show it's gonna be that show it's gonna
be debating about my fisto people we're
gonna be debating about actual politics
i mean it's from the captain america
world so i i'm all for it
um but i'm getting the hunch that next
episode the one that comes out at
midnight
that's the one that's gonna be like oh
boy
radical left disney true to its sister
from another mr series one division you
can bet that this one is
also gonna have its fair share of twists
and turns meaning it's time for us to do
what we did with wanda and friends take
a crack at breaking apart everything
that's gonna happen in the show before
episode two hits the airwaves
the streaming waves it's all just the
internet these are all the two
internet videos we can agree with that
right they're on the same status
as this show suck it disney but just
because the metaphorical bright shiny
object this time is politics doesn't
mean that marvel isn't gonna throw in
some diabolical twists and shocking
reveals and even though it's early in
the series there are definitely some
clues out there that made us think that
we might already have this
clothes clothes at least we're going to
try okay so the early stuff let's see
what you're right about
this sam wilson aka the falcon starts
the series off with an immediate twist
despite steve rogers passing on the
captain america mantle to him during the
conclusion of endgame sam decides yeah
you know what nah
hard pass instead he decides to gift the
shield to the smithsonian's captain
america exhibit
we need new heroes one suited for the
times we're in
hey i will have you know that chris
evans biceps are timeless the most
ungrateful gift getter ever anyway
instead of dying the shield sam keeps
busy in two ways the first is helping
his sister with her financially strapped
business where he comes to realize that
there are some things that not even
superheroes can overcome
that's kind of a joke but also not real
for real things always tighten around us
i'm on your side after all he's a hero
is there any chance of course you could
say no that i could get a selfie with
your arms out are you serious yeah
turns out that saving the universe
doesn't pay all that well sam's
storyline is rife with undercurrents
about american racism economic hardship
and it's a clear allegory for the unique
difficulties faced by military veterans
trying to return to normal society i
guess we can rule out avengers 5
being called subtlety war not battling
lone officers the falcon's other
preoccupation is helping friends in the
u.s army seek answers about a new group
of troublemakers calling themselves the
flag
this new group of villains wear black
and red masks and claim to believe in a
world without borders stating that
things
were better during the blip call
themselves the flag smashers was that a
new thing
bad guys give themselves bad names
basically they think that
the world is better during the blip oh
that's that's where you were saying
matpat
but he's wearing a mask like the rest of
them so we can't see who it is yet uh-oh
who's that reveal gonna be it seems like
the show wants us to wonder if bucky is
being bad again and might not even know
it himself but since the internet didn't
i didn't pick up on that at all
wolverine or deadpool or daredevil heck
i wouldn't even be surprised if there
was still some mephisto hangers on
my pistol
i believe mephisto cue the comments
wait are they friends i don't know or
was that a
jab i can't tell i mean
i don't actually know if they're friends
or if that's a gem
it seems like a good-natured rib
in either regard because i mean you guys
can clarify i remember when
voss did a whole video it was like one
of those hour long videos basically
about witches and mephisto they can
appear
in disney in china they can't appear and
they like did a whole video breaking it
down
whereas map hat's biggest argument for
why you wouldn't get like a mephisto is
because of china yeah
it's like they were the two big theory
channels and they both have very
different reasonings
for why pistol can and why mephisto
can't so i don't know if this is an
actual jab but i could i don't know this
is the other kind of people who
actually be buddies and they're just
right yeah is this let that whole thing
go on
they absolutely have to be aware of each
other oh of course no undoubtedly about
that
so i feel like it's a good natured jab
okay because i mean eric is captain
mephisto
yeah and to make everything just that
much worse for sam the first episode
ends with the shocking reveal that the
government lied about agreeing to retire
the shield
instead they announced that they've
selected their own new captain america
and unlike the original this one is not
here to be a hero for everybody
while we love heroes who put their lives
on the line to defend earth
we also need a hero to defend this
country oh and uh
for reasons i guess honestly he can't
stop having nightmares that helpfully
advance the plot also his name's in the
title of the show
so obviously a lot is already going on
but even if it's not your literal job to
dig through kevin feige's recycling bin
for youtube content you can probably see
why some people are going to be rage
posting about the show's debut episode
in one episode you've already introduced
bucky a disabled vet struggling with
ptsd
sam confronting injustice of all forms
while receiving the old thank you for
your service but not that much
one radical organization that's against
the idea of nations well the new captain
america is all about
america first i guess once your main
character is literally wearing a
country's flag as his uniform while he
runs around punching people whether you
intend to or not you're kind of telling
a story tinged with political messaging
god it hurts it hurts in the first place
marvel back before they were called
marvel put captain america punching out
hitler
well this was before the us had actually
entered world war
ii the point where much of the country
got a lot of crap for it we got a lot of
crap
and prominent political voices like the
america first movement said that we
should leave those nazis alone
bad take but it was a popular take at
the time there's captain america being
like no
i'm a flag punching him in comic book
form but now it's time to talk theories
in much the same way that a lot of fans
who knew their marvel lore were able to
guess that wandavision's agnes wasn't
really who she said she was before the
show even started airing but come as no
surprise to learn that the smug looking
guy wearing the riot cop version of a
captain america suit will turn out to be
one of the big bads of the series need
proof
well what falcon of the winter soldier
seems to be
wrote the captain america series for 10
years from 1985 to 1995
and was dedicated to using captain
america to explore real issues about
patriotism politics and american values
in a context that is mostly young
readers could respond to gruenwald made
it a point to create villains that would
be specific
to captain america as opposed to generic
foes as such
his steve rogers battled a mix of both
super villains and
real world evils like bigotry militant
groups and political corruption and also
steve was a werewolf for a while yes yes
i gotta go there 1887 captain america no
more or just the captain
arc where steve refuses to follow a
government directive he disagrees with
and is officially stripped
of his title of captain america he's
replaced by his former rival a man named
john walker and uh wouldn't you know it
but that just so happens to
also be the name of the replacement
captain in falcon in the winter soldier
and little what about this guy in the
comics walker starts as the character
super patriot a hashtag
spawn version of captain america he's
arrogant he's a sellout he's just an
all-around not good guy
for instance to boost his fame he stages
a fight against a group of fake
extremist supporters of captain america
to make it clear that
he is america's true patriot gotta say
though for as obnoxious as he is he does
have this iconic line of ma'am if uncle
sam wanted me to be mickey mouse
i'd do it anyway the tldr is that he
embodies the idea of corrupt patriotism
patriotism taken to dangerous extremes
often resorting to using extreme force
even killing people with his bare hands
he's eventually booted from the captain
america title and adopts the name u.s
agent but his use as a symbol is pretty
consistent across the franchise
he's the don't version of captain so
seeing him put on camera just looks more
and more like marvel building up to a
bad guy
avengers team something that we've
talked about in a previous yeah walker
as the anti-cap white vision as the
anti-vision evil black widow and
thaddeus ross from their new movie maybe
a return from agatha or
wanda herself and red hulk or
abomination because
every team needs their hulk of course
that is talking a long ways out but the
pieces are definitely starting to come
together let's look a bit more short
term though because here's the thing if
there's a twist in the falcon in the
winter soldier
it's probably not that the new captain
america is a bad dude
everyone can see that coming and it's
also not that zemo is gonna show up
because you know he's in the commercials
okay wait a minute so i mean john walker
i think he was gonna be revealed to be a
bad guy
it seems highly like i mean if there's
one thing that's been happening if
anything one division
proved was that there were a lot of
theories that we people were having
for some of the trailers in the first
episode they're like yeah a lot of them
did come
true yeah maybe not the most outlandish
and most crazy ridiculous ones but like
something like agatha
like like agnes and then you watch it
you're like okay i just i got the
hardness
and i feel like john walker is the
obvious setup for that like i'd be very
surprised
if they don't go down that path it won't
upset me if they do and i'm fully
expecting them to go there
especially with everything that they
talked about with him planting the seeds
of who john walker
represents in the comics the corrupt
patriot as
put here and what i find so cool about
what this show is already setting up to
do then i hope they really commit to it
is from talking about just in this video
alone what the comics explored
and then you think about the captain
america movies yeah
and they don't really go all out with
exploring
the themes it's there within the dna of
captain america you know like
not believing in the sokovia accords not
siding with shield when he learns what's
going on in winter soldier
and his origin in captain america but
this show ironically that doesn't have
steve rogers seems like it's gonna be
going
way more in to the heavier stuff that
the comics
were able to do that the movies have not
done with the captain america world just
yet
absolutely yeah that that's my entire
hope for this yeah
so let's instead talk about the flag
smashers in the comics flag smasher not
an extremist group but rather just one
dude was another mark gruenwald creation
he's pretty much supposed to be a super
villain anti-patriot who believes that
national allegiances no matter what they
are
are responsible for the world's evils as
such he tries to make sense
all world governments through his
network ultimatum which
i am not kidding was an acronym for get
this
underground liberated totally integrated
mobile army to unite mankind yeah that
is somehow that's
that's my acronym yeah it stands for
awkward and ridiculous dumb verb
entertaining real cringe you gotta spell
cringe with a k to make it work
also flag smasher had a mace for
smashing flags i don't know maces just
make everything cooler anyway it's
probably for the bases
smasher group in the show only seems to
be taking the name and the general
ideology but you can immediately see how
the flag smashers make sense as a
villain for a series about who gets to
be the new captain america they're
against
national symbols captain america is one
of those
national symbols cut and dry except
there's one major
problem with this the mouse think about
it the mcu is
all about connecting okay here we go
here we go what's going on movies
characters and streaming shows this
media empire is built on people from
different backgrounds assembling
how else can we have a norse god of
thunder and an i shoot arrows good man
team up connection
is good in this series walls and
isolationism
is bad it's a confluence of corporate
creative synergy so organically executed
that you can feel the ghost of
walt disney himself saluting from
beneath the matterhorn or his cryogenic
freezing tube or wherever they're
preserving his body
pro global not only delivers a
progressive feel good message
it comes with the added perk that the
whole globe now wants to buy your merch
in this way disney's interests seem to
agree with the ideology
if not the methods of the flag smashers
which begs the question why would a
studio set up a bunch of characters who
espouse pretty much a punk rock version
of not only their entire franchise
philosophy but also their entire
business model to be the villains
of their series they wouldn't unless
they wanted to look like
that's what they were doing to surprise
the audience and deliver a pointed
message about what heroes are meant to
look like
oh i get where you're going with this
and that my friends is why we're calling
it at least one of the big secrets
waiting to be unveiled in the falcon in
the winter so
that the flag smashers are not the big
bad
show wants us to think they are after
all in the comics even the
original flag smasher actually turned
against ultimatum when he learned that
some of his then
we learned the acronym the red skull so
in a similar vein could it be that the
flag smashers in the show
mean well but are actually being misled
by a villain manipulating them from
behind the scenes
maybe someone like zemo who has shown in
civil war that that's exactly how he
likes to operate
oh i love this i love this if he's just
so
cool if red skull was like i am in
charge that the flag smashes from before
me
because i am so [ __ ] bored i
finds a way across time and space
dimensions oh i know what it's all
hydras too um
the only thing we couldn't do is find
mephisto we both did not do a good
german accent there
you especially went very transylvanian
what they're talking about uh with the
flag smashers they're like the group
and ready player one mm-hmm you know how
there's like there's gonna be that one
female character who's probably gonna
get along with like
you know it was one of them like torres
or somebody like
bucky or sam maybe and then whoever that
actress is forget her name but
you you with the flag smashers they are
like the ready player one
terrorist group when you're like oh no
they're actually good
they're fighting the good fight yeah
it's the it's the bad
things they're making corporate people
yeah it has been like taking control of
and brainwashed and
forced into this i think that's a yeah
i'm pretty confident
that the first half will play that way
but then in the end they'll be like you
know
we're not so different to you and i well
and that can help further diverge from
just the the
binary of good guys and bad guys and
especially exactly political show like
people get sucked into ideologies for
all
kinds of reasons oh yeah no 100 john i
agree with you on everything you just
said
that's why you're john humphrey as for
what that means or how it specifically
plays out well that's
probably a bit too early to say
especially given that both bucky and
zemo being back raises the possibility
that we're dealing with mind control and
people being puppeteered into doing
evil's bidding
or maybe more likely the flag smashers
don't exist at all and the government
just made up a false flag threat so john
walker is captain america
arch enemy my money's actually on that
one that the flag smasher is actually an
inside job i don't have a lot of proof
to point out for that one but i like the
narrative angle and it's very
reminiscent of the walker origin story
that i mentioned before where he attacks
a fake
group of extremists supporting captain
america to achieve national
headlines and buy-in for himself or
this one is admittedly the long shot
what if there was a recurring captain
america franchise character who was
almost always absent for long
unexplained periods of time but also
always
[Music]
someone who is scheduled to i think he's
uh
misleading what if that character sharon
carter oh he's going to share it
there's going to be an artist that red
skull has himself a daughter maybe she
inherits the family business
just saying they're all just theories
film
theories and cuts
[Music]
let's grab him you can just hold him in
your hand guys
no i think they are bad i think they're
both bad
the flag smashers and uh i think i think
they're both that yeah
yeah i mean i think i feel like they'll
team up with the flag smashers halfway
through or something i feel like the way
marvel is going to proceed especially in
these series is they got to give us a
couple where it's like
okay that seems like it's pretty primed
to happen and it will
and then here's like a side surprise you
weren't even considering
i mean i think that what these shows do
really well and i feel like what
falcon and winter soldier will also deal
with is perspectives
kind of like a damn good anime when you
like dive into the
perspectives you start to realize oh
this person's actually not the bad oh
this person is actually the ba you know
that
kind of deal yeah so uh yeah guys i
think it's going to be some good
[ __ ] i'm excited for the next episode
that comes out
in a few hours let's sleep
no don't ever bring that word up around
this house again
what what i don't even know what it
means to sleep all week
oh my gosh let's just go and knock out
for
seven straight [ __ ] all right completely
missed why we were here all right guys
thank you so much for being here keep a
look out for everything else that comes
out in our lives
hopefully some stuff comes out next week
it's okay john you're one man see you
guys
[Music]